thank you
i i know it's a pandemic and i
definitely am in favor of fewer people
than more people being present for a
celebration
but that felt a little flat as you walk
through the door maybe that's not the
video that you put on social media
when they walk in and the reaction is
like
oh and there's like five people in the
room anyway sam darnold he was putting
on that carolina blue hat at the end
because he's now a member of the
carolina panthers as he starts
stage two of his nfl career shireen and
and uh joe douglas the jets gm met with
reporters today
he was asked questions about what this
means for the jets moving forward with
the second overall pick in the draft and
there was an interesting exchange
as it relates to inside information that
steve young believes that he has
regarding the jet's plans here's the
back and forth with joe douglas
think of steve young's comments on the
radio apparently he did some detective
work and spoke to some members of the
coaching staff and he said the jets are
quote committed
to zach wilson uh
steve's uh steve's plugged into byu
pretty well
i know it was good being out there
at the pro day and uh just had an
opportunity to
you know speak to his representatives um
say hello to
a couple members of his family quickly
um
and you know byu put on a great pro day
for for the entire nfl first class uh
first class organization and
uh it was a good day out there you know
um
[Music]
like i said we're we're excited about
this class and we're excited about this
quarterback class so
we still have a lot of our process left
in these three plus
weeks leading up to the draft and a lot
of productive conversations
conversations in the future coming up
no reason to be coy when you are on the
clock after trevor lawrence is taken by
the jaguars and the worst possible
outcome would be that the jaguars
don't take trevor lawrence and then you
can take trevor lawrence either way
the jets are guaranteed to get a great
quarterback it's going to be lawrence
it's going to be wilson and it sure
sounds like
it's going to be wilson yeah doesn't it
mike
i i'm going to be very surprised that
the jets don't take wilson and
one thing that's intriguing to me when
you go back and you look at the 49ers
trade up to number three
they never called the jets right and you
think about all the people who have gone
from the 49ers to the jets
and i'm sure they had some sort of intel
that the jets were locked in on a
quarterback and they
probably know who the jets are locked in
on which is we all expect to be
zach wilson so they were going to get
their guy at number three that's why you
pulled the trigger on that trade at that
time because you know you can get your
guy that you want at number three so all
signs might point to zach wilson going
to the jets he's a cheaper option than
sam darnold was about to be
who will be on his fifth year option in
2022 last year of his rookie deal coming
up this year
a cheaper option and they think an
upgrade otherwise you don't make this
deal
yeah absolutely and this is a team that
is trying to find a franchise
quarterback the three categories of
teams you remember
one the team that has the franchise
quarterback two the team that's
desperately looking
for one and three the team that has a
guy that they're not quite sure about
well they got rid of the guy they're not
quite sure about
so now they're back to category two
desperately looking for their next
franchise quarterback we did a draft
earlier today on pft live shireen of all
of the disappointing jets quarterbacks
over the years from
richard todd to browning nagel and the
list goes on and on
and and the reality is if you
take your shot and it works great you
got a quarterback for 10 15 maybe 20
years given the way that
quarterbacks are protecting themselves
and and working out and eating right and
focused on their career and their craft
and if it doesn't work out you'll be
back
in two or three years to do it again
just like the jets were after giving up
three second round picks to move from
six to three
three years ago to get sam darnold maybe
a different gm maybe a different coach
still the same team and the team's goal
is to get
that franchise quarterback douglas also
acknowledged that it's important not to
just have a franchise quarterback
but to make sure that you have enough
pieces around
that quarterback to be successful here's
douglas on the supporting cast
for their next franchise quarterback at
least hopeful franchise quarterback
there's a lot of people fired up in this
building about not only the talent
that we brought into the building in in
the locker room
but the caliber of character that we uh
we signed and brought into this locker
room so
um you know we talked about the the
those acquisitions and then like i
mentioned earlier these assets that we
have
through the draft and so it's incumbent
on on
us to get these decisions right um
whether it's turning the card in turning
the pick in or trading
uh for a proven commodity we
we have to uh surround our
next quarter quarterback uh with as much
talent as possible
they've got two first-round picks this
year two first-round picks next year
they've picked up
more and they really didn't give up you
know well they they don't get
they got a little bit more not much for
sam darnold but but they're in great
shape
to build a young team around him but you
do have to get the pics right
and that's on joe douglas who's been
doing a lot over the past couple of
years to clean up the messes made by his
predecessors
and that's why the jets are in the
position they're in right now
is because they didn't draft that well
when they got it right say
jamal adams they traded that piece away
leonard williams traded that piece away
so when they've gotten it right they
haven't held on to those guys
but mike they do have six of the first
107 picks in this draft
they're going to get an opportunity to
really build around
zach wilson or whoever they choose at
quarterback moving forward so they're
going to get a lot of starters
presumably out of this draft they just
got to make sure that they draft wisely
and they end up with a lot of starters
out of this draft
the best approach have maximum lottery
tickets they are all
unscratched lottery tickets and you get
a lot of them and you're going to get
some players who can help your team
get better hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights
from nbc sports